فيضانات مدسوسه مياه ملغمه ليس الفيضان
وحده ما يغمر المدينه هنا بل في جوف
المياه كوارث موقوته
نهر النيبرو المستهدف سده صباحا فاض
بالمياه والاف الالغام ايضا جرفت المياه
اغلب الالغام الى قلب المدينه لتعلو
الكارثه بمنسوب وجد فيها مسؤولون انها
الاخطر من الفيضان ذاته
اعتادت كل من روسيا واوكرانيا وضع الالغام
للحفاظ على حدودهما نهريه روسيا تسيطر على
الجهه اليمنى من النهر فيما تسيطر
اوكرانيا على الضفه اليمنى وما بينهما
حادثه قصف لسد نوفاك خوفكا يترشق الطرفان
المسؤوليه فيما بينهما
مفارقه المياه بالسنتيمتر الواحد تؤرق
مسؤولين مخاوف من ارتفاع منسوب المياه وسط
المدينه ورعب من انخفاض منسوب مياه
التبريد في منشاه نوويه كارثتان باتتا
قريبتين وفق مسؤولين
مفارقه اخرى لكن على بعد 150 كيلومترا هذه
المره فبينما يصارع هؤلاء للهرب بعيدا عن
80 قريه غمرتها المياه يحتاط سكان شرقي
اوكرانيا من تهديد بالعطش فما ملامح
انقطاع المياه بات جليا على الرف هنا غذاء
السالم العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات